in this video i'm going to talk to you
about how to structure the business in
order to sell it and why you should do
that independent of whether or not
you're planning on selling it
in the future so hi my name is alex mozi
i have a portfolio companies that does
just under 100 million
a year in revenue we own three outright
we have five that we have minority
positions in
and i have absolutely nothing to sell
you and the reason i make this channel
is because lots of people are broke
and i don't want you to be one of them
if you have a business right now and
you're trying to scale it you're trying
to grow it
there's usually one of two outcomes
right either this is a is something that
you're super passionate about um or this
is an opportunity that you're passionate
about because of the you know upside
potential of making lots of money
there's tons of people who really you
know build software companies they're
not like super passionate about like
data management but they're really good
at it and they think there's an
opportunity to make money it doesn't
really matter to me whatever way you do
it is fine
but what happens is over the trajectory
of the careers of the entrepreneur
you know we develop in skill sets we
level level up you know first we're
doing that we're managing that we're
leading then we're casting the vision
and you move your way up in the company
as the company grows underneath of you
as you scale
right the thing is is that at some point
you know i think the entrepreneurial
journey is always trying to find the
most leverage
for our skills like what's the best
vehicle for the skills that we have
to capitalize on the opportunity
marketplace right and that's the entire
market not just within the context of
your business
but if you were building the company at
some point and this i think
one of the hardest transitions that i've
had to go through and it took me a very
long time to do this
was transitioning from ceo to owner and
you've heard me talk about this before
but i'm gonna say it again because i
think it's so important
independent of whether i plan on keeping
the businesses or selling the businesses
learning how to structure the business
so that it could sell someday
was one of the most valuable things that
i've done as an entrepreneur and i
remember when i started out as like i'm
never going to sell this company i'm
never going to sell this company like
i'm going to keep these things for life
and that may or may not be true but as
i've gotten older i will tell you this i
do like having optionality
and by structuring the company in such a
way that i could sell it which i'm going
to get to what's
what some of those things are in a
second it actually enabled me to have
more freedom which was the ultimate goal
of the business
and so the biggest hardship that i've
probably
enforced on myself was starting another
business while i had a business which is
probably one of the questions i get most
frequently from entrepreneurs was like
well you say i should be focusing on
stuff but you have all these businesses
and the answer is yes and part of that
is because i made mistakes and i'm
hopefully
hoping that you don't have to make the
same ones that i did coming up which is
i was ceo of one company and then
started a second company because i
wasn't doing anything
in my first company or wasn't going to
plan on doing anything in my second
company i was like i can be ceo of both
terrible mistake it cost me dearly in
time and stress and all the other things
that go along with that
but being ceo is a full-time role
and so unless you are truly the owner of
a company
and not the ceo then that company still
needs you and it means it's a not
sellable or
sellable for much less because it's
still dependent on you as the owner
and i remember i used to poo poo this
when i was you know earlier on in
starting my career i was like i would
hear guru say like and maybe it's
because i didn't know how to do it but
they were like you know if
business can't run without you it's not
a real business well i don't think it's
not a real business
i'd think that you are not an owner if
it cannot run without you or you're an
owner but you're also a ceo
of the company and so for me
understanding the difference between ceo
and owner was really important because
only i didn't even have any examples of
that right it was only when i started
looking at the investor word the wealth
world that i understand the difference
between those two things
and so as an easy example like if you
look at warren buffett he doesn't run
c's candy he owns these candies right he
doesn't
run geico he owns geico and he doesn't
own you know
ben bridges jewelers or whatever it is
like he owns it he doesn't run it
and so if you think about that within
the context of you know your businesses
is like is there
a way that this business could not only
maintain but also grow
without my involvement whatsoever so
that i could function the same way i do
in the stock market as somebody who's in
it who owns equity in this company that
it grows without
me now let me explain how my role works
now because i have been able to
structure my life so that i actually
treat
all portfolio companies the same so
despite the fact that i have 100
ownership in three of them and i have
you know
minority stakes in the other five i
still structure my engagements with them
the same way
so i'm still meeting quarterly with
those those companies and their
leadership teams and i have
you know meetings as needed with them
throughout and
one of the important pieces is that i am
nose-in hands out
so you can write that one down like niho
and i got that from a mentor of mine
no zen hands out which means that when
we have a meeting or we have a you know
a long talk or we want to talk about
something strategic
i don't walk away from meeting with with
with homework i don't walk away with to
do's
all right and that is a purposeful
effort by design because if i had to
walk with to do's from all these
companies then i would i would never be
able to get anything done right
and so i go into there as a strategic
advisor i'm there to offer my experience
but i'm not there to lead the meeting
i'm there to bounce
ideas off of and the way to make that
transition is that you have to build it
without intention
so as i've now built businesses later in
my career compared to earlier my career
my earlier businesses i built
independency on myself because i had
those interpersonal needs
and i also didn't know any better but
hopefully if you're watching this you
can know better
and so this is one of the downsides of
having a personality-based brand
compared to a business that's faceless
that's really just a brand in and of
itself that's outside of the
entrepreneur or owner
who started it right sees candies it's
not about
warren buffett geico is not about warren
buffett they have a gecko right and
that's the the mascot and so
as i've transitioned through this i can
tell you that now finally i would say
i'm in a position where i actually am
an owner and it's awesome it's great
these companies pump out cash flow and i
can allocate that cash flow
accordingly and you know buy percentage
of other companies i can get real estate
all these other things
but it comes from literally being able
to do that
which means that i either have to bring
someone up to operate as ceo so right
now your business does not have a ceo
and you say that you are passive in it i
would
probably challenge you on that and say
that's not true right the company has to
be able to grow
and innovate without you if it can do
that then it passes my test of ownership
right and so i i like to have a certain
amount of involvement which i just said
like quarterly and you know touch points
and things like that
but beyond those things the business
must be able to operate and grow on its
own and a test that i have is that in a
six month period after i leave and i put
someone else in charge
does the company grow during that period
of time not only maintain
but grow in both top lane and profit
unless there was you know
some reason they wanted to make some
sort of capital investment or whatever
but for the most part
you can use your own common sense there
but that is my litmus test it's six
months
so if i put someone new in and i give
them six months
does the company grow without my
involvement switching to this
communication cadence
and i think one of the hardest and most
significant things that you can do to
really remove yourself from that is if
you have any sort of central
communication
for the company so if you have slack or
asana or some place that you
that you are you know integrally
involved you see everything
if you can remove yourself from that if
you can get off of the company slack if
you can get off of the company asana
so that no one can have contact with you
and you can start a separate
communication center which is what we
have done with our portfolio we just
have one slack that has all of the
executives
from each of those portfolio companies
so they are the only ones who have
direct access to us
and their teams have access to them
directly and that is how we can have far
more leverage
with the skill sets that we have given
the opportunities the marketplace and so
the important point here that i want to
make is that independent of whether you
plan on selling
or you plan on keeping your company
structuring your company so that you can
sell it will ultimately give you the
freedom
that you want and this was something
that i did not do earlier on in my
career it's taken me years i mean
now over a decade to get to this point
and i can tell you
i don't think i'll ever build another
company again the way i used to
and i think part of that comes with
skill sets part of that comes with
beliefs part of that is
character traits that you develop over
time but hopefully we can fast track
that which is why i'm making these
videos for you so
i hope you found that valuable um hit
subscribe if it was
for you i'm trying to help entrepreneurs
who are trying to scale their companies
and just kind of show you the lessons
that i've learned along the way
the the key point is ownership
is the goal not ceo ship and if we can
act as owners i think we make better
long-term decisions you are far less
stressed about short-term nuances in the
business because you have a much more
long-term outlook and ultimately i think
it actually better serves the business
in the long run
um in terms of the value that it creates
for its customers so and honestly the
value that the business creates for you
in your life which i think most of us
wanted freedom
um and it takes a long time to get here
so anyways hope that was bad before you
leave a comment if you like
uh stuff like this and if you have other
questions around these topics and stuff
i love talking about
um and i just want to make stuff that
you find you know that's useful for you
so anyways lots of love and i'll see you
next video